hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to power wash simulator
there's been an update to this game and
i know oh hey
i thought that there was more
probably after this probably definitely
after this okay well i guess i gotta
play this one too i gotta i say
in all reality i do not mind playing it
but say lavi is this right gun yeah
ooh is there a new gun
damn it
damn it is there new stuff damn it
is there any clothing i don't like the
orange
the orange is working for me
but the pink is nice let's go pink
oh
my oh
that's
beautiful
oh that's gorgeous
oh that's gorge
oh
[Laughter]
wow
i know i'm probably full up on this but
whatever all right let's get to clean
[Music]
it's a hell of a thing to come back to
this after a non-stop barrage of uh
doing nothing but filming
and i know that this is kind of the
thing that i did before filming started
and now filming is all done and filming
is also a very meticulous thing that
takes a lot of effort and a lot of
planning a lot of careful methodical
work
but at the same time is also interrupted
by sprints of doing an incredible amount
of work very quickly so it's kind of a
mixture
and now it's all done which is god so
weird i mean there's still some minor
things left to film but
for the most part
like filming for uh in space with
markiplier which i can now say
is done
and wow that is just something
incredible to be able to say that it's
been so long that it's been in planning
that to finally be here
today and being like oh yeah it's
done done
like it's still being edited of course
and there's still a lot to do there but
just like the fact that
it's now done and it's going to be
edited and i don't have to film it
anymore i don't have any more writing to
do i feel like i've been talking about
writing it
and spending time working on writing it
for so long
that i'm just kind of like starting to
understand that it's now done and i
don't have to do any more writing for it
and i'm kind of
i mean i'm not free it's not it's not
the thing about like being free you know
i don't want to be free but it's still
just like wow i can't believe that that
that part of my life which has taken
over a year to plan and come up with and
do is is nearly done
and all that's left is just to enjoy it
while editing it and we have to pick up
a few shots here and there but a man i
can't wait for you guys to see it it's
so much more
ambitious
than a heist with markiplier was and a
heist with markiplier was very ambitious
don't get me wrong like i'm not saying
that
you know 60 some odd videos with uh
however many endings there were i don't
even remember now
wasn't ambitious but man space is just
so much more ambitious i
i can't even explain to you how much
i oh god i can't talk about it because i
can't spoil anything but i just
oh
i just can't wait for you guys to see it
it's something really special
and uh we had a great time filming it
too but now it's uh filming is done
god filming stunning so i can kind of
take this moment oh look at this thing's
dick
look at that thing's floppy dick it must
be hard for this thing to drag it around
like this oh well
alas sorry it's that
distractible energy still getting in my
head
we just got done reading uh reading the
ads for distractible which is a funny
thing to say
but man we have fun reading the ads
this is kind of like what i've always
wanted which is companies just like let
us do whatever the hell we want for ads
and we can make as many jokes as we want
which has been i don't know very nice
kind of a freeing experience so if i
want to talk about this
fire helicopter's giant elephant trunk
dick
flopping out of the back of it i
apologize it's just because that's in my
brain right now also listen to
distractible have you not listened to
distractible yet my god what are you
doing with your life
it's the one thing i've kept consistent
while filming the project
man i had so many ambitions for
ambitions for keeping videos regular and
consistent while i was here i i don't
know why
i try because man it was
just goddamn impossible but i'm finally
going back home
very soon now
and i'm going to be getting back in a
regular schedule and i'm going to be
making videos and i'm gonna have so much
to provide for you in terms of that
sweet delicious content but
to start off i just kind of have to do
stuff like this
i mean not that this isn't sweet
delicious content but i enjoy it too
i enjoy all the videos that i make don't
get me wrong there's nothing i really do
that i don't
force myself to go through just to make
you guys happy there are a few games
that i have in mind that i'm going to
intentionally suffer through mostly just
because
uh it's things that you guys have been
asking for forever but now i'm gonna
actually go through them i'm goosed on
co2 sorry i missed that who's goose on
co2 what does that even mean
[Music]
okay this is an idea just to give you an
idea of what kind of videos i want to do
i need a list and this is where i need
you guys help i need a list of all the
games that i have not finished
and i need this to be a comprehensive
list because i kind of want to as a
challenge for myself
to see how many of them i can finish and
i mean like any game at any point on my
channel that i did not finish this is
not a promise that i'm going to finish
them
understand that right now that's not a
promise that i'm going to finish them
i'm not going to be completionist about
this but there are some experiences that
i kind of want to go back to
because i'm kind of i'm kind of like oh
man why didn't i finish that because um
condemned criminal origins and this is
going way
way back on my channel but condemned
criminal origins was a game uh that came
out for like the xbox 360 back in the
day uh and it's a horror game and it was
very good it was very scary but i
remember i ran into like this game
breaking bug
that i couldn't finish or no it was like
my save got corrupted or something like
that
and i didn't finish it and i'm wondering
about going back and finishing that game
and it got me thinking of like huh i
wonder what other games that there have
been over the years that i have not
finished and i would want to do just
like one video where i just finish
that particular game and not worry about
like doing not picking it up as a series
but just kind of like polishing off
these old games
anyway if you guys can provide me a list
to that
in some kind of organized way
that i could see exactly what it is i've
left kind of half done on my channel
and again no guarantee i'm actually
gonna do it because i'm lazy
but
maybe man what happened to this
helicopter did it go through a fire or
something
god it's been a while it is it is
strange how rusty i get from doing let's
plays and how much i i've had one time
when i was trying to do a video and i
for some reason couldn't even get
through like the first minute of like
saying my intro and saying hello and
just like getting through the normal
process i hadn't even gotten into the
video yet and i remember i like get up
from my computer i'm like start
screaming because i can't i literally
like i've been fraught i can't do it
i've forgotten how to do anything i
don't even know how to talk anymore and
so i run down screaming davey and i'm
just like i'm a frog
and then she's like yeah you're a fraud
yeah yeah well you just gotta fake it
for a little bit longer man i'm like
what are you being a little bit longer
what are you talking about and i
realized i was talking to a cryptid
version of amy and it wasn't actually
amy and then i
ran away screaming at the top of my
lungs
uh it eventually got me and killed me
i'm dead
like i said i don't know what the hell
i'm doing anymore
but i have remembered to be meticulous
about this
[Music]
the problem about being meticulous about
some things is i don't exactly know what
it is
i guess i could do that
yeah i've i've known about the tab for a
while but i always feel like it's a bit
of a cheat but on some things it is very
difficult to tell what is still dirty
also it's not the worst thing in the
world i i sometimes i was like i don't
like the glow on the the playback but at
the same time
that's kind of nice wow this is still
very dirty
oh my god it's incredibly dirty
okay maybe i should have been doing that
a while ago because this is very obvious
that there's so many things left that
need to be cleaned but this should be
done at least not seeing much else oh
there we go oh i see
okay i see it's the nooks and crannies
that i never would have gotten to okay
you should be done now and yet you're
not
hmm
oh the tippy top of course oh i'm an
idiot
[Music]
oh this is doing nothing
this is doing nothing
[Music]
god it's so much easier seeing what you
have to clean if only i had known about
this oh so long ago
if only i had known about it if only
someone told me about it if only someone
out there trusted me enough to know this
information if only someone out there
cared enough to tell me about this i
would have
saved myself so much heartache and
trouble how could you guys let me go
without this knowledge i'm an i
apologize i can feel your blood pressure
raising
i'm sorry this is supposed to be a
relaxing time for all of us to enjoy and
yet here i am
being a jackass
there we go and then the tire
there we go
okay
so that's most of the
never mind
i take it all back that's not most of
anything
[Music]
letting this chief know about my
predicament saved my smokey bacon i owe
you one i don't know what that is
referring to is that something about
being hopped up on co2
because i wasn't paying attention to
that and you should probably talk to a
professional about that
[Music]
one of these days i'm going to try to
clean an entire thing with just this
power washer
to see if it's actually easier because
once you hit something with this you
know it's clean i mean even this
like you could do the whole thing with
just this
and that way you know it's done although
it is a very tiny little beam
and maybe this would be better yeah i
don't know i don't know what would be
better
[Music]
sorry i was just in a transfer a bit
there
yeah but filming was great like being on
set we had a lot of the same people that
were part of heist
uh so that was good because number one
they made it easier so we didn't have to
tell people
uh about how it was going to be shot and
kind of the idea that it was first
person you know it was less people that
needed to get into the idea as a whole
and more people they were just able to
like pick up where they left off with
the last one but also this one was
different because it was just such a
different beast and you know it was more
involved and had a lot of a lot more
chaos to it and like connective pieces
uh so it was good to have people there
that didn't have to have the sticker
shock of suddenly being like i don't
know what the hell i'm working on
there's more people that like because
because the project is so diverse right
it's so
it's so complicated it goes all over the
place it's like it's a two-year-old
adventure it's an interactive and so
when it comes down to that how the
storyline connects from the pieces that
we're actually practically filming
because the concept of filming it is
completely different from just writing
it you know actually practically how do
you do these things in what order do you
film this like in what locations do you
have to be to film things and how do
they connect back like when things go
back and forth all over the place a lot
of the times the connected tissue isn't
apparent i mean you guys can trolly try
to imagine it like how we shot heist you
know if you if you see the different
locations just understand sometimes
we're at the same place but not on the
same days so we got to film things out
of order like completely out of order
and the whole show is kind of already
out of order so
space is a different beast entirely and
having the same people there just to
trust in me
oh it's such an honor to have people
trust me like that just being like yeah
mark knows that that's like a common
slogan on set he's like yeah mark knows
mark's got it mark's got his head which
is great in terms of having faith in me
but also stressful because i'm like ah
what if i don't have it guys maybe you
shouldn't trust me that much maybe maybe
we should all have it you know all at
once but now we did it and i did have it
and i'm very proud of myself for working
on this hard i had it just because i've
been working on it for over a year you
know when you get it when you start
working on something that long you end
up just really really knowing the thing
i
love just working on this kind of stuff
i love it
it's it's one of the greatest joys that
i could ever have
just being able to
make things that i only imagine in my
head come to life and and push myself
and like stretch my ambitions and
stretch my
my ideas like farther than i thought
possible and
having people along for the ride that
are just like hell yeah this is fun this
is cool we love this uh in terms of like
i don't know if you know for the product
when it comes out who knows like it
still needs to be edited i think it's
good but you never know what that's kind
of stuff um but as far as like the
filming of its like the project i i was
so honored because people told me that
it was just a very fun experience and it
was it was a good be on the set and you
know they just trusted in what i was
doing that's just
i'm honored to have their trust and
have their time especially you know
because it's a job yeah it's of course
it's the job but i don't think people
get into creative jobs like
filmmaking and you know
production stuff
because it's just like a 95 they do it
because they love it you know they they
love making things and they love being
on set and they love
having
the set experience and like
seeing visions come to life it's
that's great and so i never want to take
that for granted
i never want to assume
that people
just give me their time because they
believe in my product my project 110 you
know all the time i i want to try to
like make them fall in love with what
i'm doing
because i feel like that makes it even
more special and it makes them
want to put their best foot forward when
it comes to making things every day and
coming into work um because if they love
it then they're gonna love making it and
they can't wait to see it come to life
and i know it was just so nice because
maybe made stickers for everybody uh to
have just like on a whim because amy's
just so good about giving gifts and
stuff like that um so amy
made these stickers like made about 100
of them for people to come in and and it
was from a slogan from the show
and people had them and and they they
just picked them up and they were like
yeah of course i
would love to have this and people just
it's small gestures like that that
really make people fall in love with the
product because it like helps them
connect to it and help them feel part of
it and it's just like it's so innate to
what amy does and it's just like oh man
i never would have thought of that i
never would have thought of giving
people a keepsake and this was very
early in the production so it was like
giving people an opportunity to have
something to keep and take home about it
that early oh it's just it's brilliant
you know it really is and anyway also
trying to keep everything secret was a
goddamn nightmare just like absolutely
there's another good thing that came out
of it you remember we moved into
florence old place no i don't remember
that because i don't know who the hell
you are well guess who's a copter pilot
now
you
is this your copter
okay good
i'm just cleaning it man
anyway it's rude to text on a date so i
better go
yeah you know a little bit maybe you
should pay attention to your date yeah
maybe you shouldn't be talking to me
yeah why don't you go well you go let me
get out of here well apparently i'm 60
done
[Music]
something about this drive shaft is not
done
not sure what though
if only i could see oh
i think it's all that all that is the
drive shaft okay so all that counts
together
why
[Music]
hey
well i've entered into the uh spooky
zone of
power simulator
uh wow okay
um i'm gonna just
nope okay let's go to the main menu
let's get into something else uh let's
just go to mars real quick because
apparently that's where i'm going anyway
let's restart that
return that i'll be any clean products
we'll lose uh
okay guess not
uh
challenge mode any new challenges hey
look back wa garden let's try for the
challenge okay and then all right cool
now we're gonna yeah three two one and
i'm really gonna try oh you know what i
give up because i i can't stand the
competition um
let's try that again
please don't put me where i was
okay good
all right well okay good and good my my
thing is here great
good stuff
anyway let's forget about that nightmare
that happened no one's gonna pay any
attention to that it's all good here
[Music]
so i know this probably isn't the most
therapeutic to look at but this kind of
machinery probably isn't just it's it's
not going to be an easy one to wash all
these little nooks and crannies are just
going to be a pain in the ass so i'm
going to have to hammer it pretty hard
[Music]
no step huh uh it's more of a suggestion
than anything
i don't look to stuff like that for
guidance probably no step on this either
i would imagine probably pretty delicate
but whatever
[Music]
god this is gonna be a nightmare this is
where i wish i had a water grenade
just blast it in there i know i probably
should do the soap for this one but
man apparently there's only so much soap
that you can get oh there's only so much
soap
or can't have too much soap oh
[Music]
you know what's funny is like everyone
on on set always asks me like what i
want to do
after youtube
and it's such a funny question it's like
after youtube as if there's some other
aspiration to do
besides youtube
uh because because i i get the question
i get where it's coming from it's coming
from people that are of a traditional
entertainment mindset and they they
think about film productions as like
the pinnacle of what you would want to
do as far as entertainment goes um but
i've found a niche where i can do both
all all at once i i love youtube and and
you know maybe it's not the end all of
what i do forever and ever because i
doubt that i'm going to be doing let's
plays when i'm 60
[Music]
so i don't think that maybe i will who
knows what i'm gonna be doing who knows
what am i doing but as far as like
what i do
after youtube it's like it's such a such
a nonsensical question because
i just love making things and
youtube
as a platform allows me to make things
whatever i want there may be a platform
that's better for that you know in the
long run there may be a platform that
allows me to make these complicated
narrative things that i want to do these
higher production things that i want to
do there may come a platform like that
and who knows maybe maybe i will make a
movie that i try to take to a film
festival or stuff like that
but as far as like my bread and butter
just like creative outlet and that's
what we're really talking about here is
just a creative outlet like there's no
better place for me
than youtube right now it's just where i
want to make things and it's it's not
even so much where i want to make things
it's where i can make things so long as
i'm able to do that i'm i'm going to
keep doing that really is no other place
to be
you know i just like creating things i
like imagining i like
i like just
da
gotta i love production too there's so
much to love about
being on set and working with people and
there's so much to love about working by
myself in a room where i'm able to film
videos like this there's so much to love
about all of it there's there's so many
pieces to it there's it's not just one
thing like a lot of people try to boil
down creation to just lift one thing and
what are you gonna do next is if there's
always a ladder to climb and it's like
the ladder is what you make for yourself
right it's the challenges that i put in
my
in my way that i've
intentionally put there because i needed
to do stuff like i always will challenge
myself to make
make new things and make bigger things
and make different things and like
that's always going to be a baseline i'm
never going to be satisfied with what i
do but at the same time that's kind of
like a past tense future tense thing
it's like once i make something i'm very
satisfied in the moment but as soon as
it's done i'm like man moving on to the
next thing like time to make something
better than that i always look at the
mistakes that i made on that production
and i'm like okay time to take the
lessons that i learned there already
even on this one i have a lot of
mistakes and stuff that i've learned
that'll help me in future projects
and so i'm just like okay all right i
learned a lot on that one time to apply
that to the next project and i think
like for me that's such a beautiful
thing it means that you know i don't
dwell too much on the success of the now
and i don't dwell too much on like oh
yeah i did that and i can breathe and
relax it's like no i
i just love making so much that i can't
wait to make the next thing and when i
learn something that i can do to make it
better i just keep doing it i have the
same application for like some games
that i play
i was recently playing oxygen not
included on my own and i i kept running
into this thing where i would get so far
in the game and then i would restart and
play it again and i would just keep
doing that and i would never make a lot
of progress
but i was having an incredible amount of
fun
because every time that i played again i
learned something new and i was like
obsessed about getting the perfect
start of something
and it it's like it's weird because i
got to points where i was finished where
i was like okay i'm done and then
immediately i'd be like i can't wait to
start over again i'm for some reason i
just really like the idea of starting
over
it's it's always been something that i
enjoy
you know whether it's bleeding channels
or you know just like starting a new
project i love the beginning of it i
love the seeds of an idea i love the the
the opening
sequences you know it's like ah this is
i love it i love it so much there's just
so much i want to do yeah man i've got
so much left to make
and i like i was telling amy i was i was
kind of getting emotional once the
filming was done and
i i don't even think filming was done
but you know i was i was looking at
everything and i was just like holy
this one's almost done and i kind of got
emotional because i was like
i'm not done
like i'm not done making i i've got so
much more that i want to do i've got so
much more that i want to make i mean
that's that's all i ever think about is
like my god i just can't wait to make
the next thing and i know for some
people that's probably insanity but for
me it's the only way that i can live
i just
i love doing what i do i love it all i
love this i love i love this just as
much as i love like making a vlog or i
love this as much as i love making part
17 of some
inane let's play that people have lost
interest in so long ago or i love it as
much as i like dumping one video game uh
because i got bored with it and i was
like yeah it's time to move on like
that's just how i am that's just like
how i approach everything i i can't help
it
like all of it is is it's part of me and
i i don't even try to question it
anymore i just i just keep doing
i just keep doing
always and forever just keep doing
[Music]
until the day i die and then i'll stop
doing so
but whatever such is life and that comes
for us all eventually and i shall not
worry about it and i shall worry more
about cleaning this goddamn airplane
helicopter what am i cleaning i have no
idea
get clean you my god this is
never gonna get clean
there's so many small little crevices
you know what i i
mentioned it briefly uh in another video
i don't know when that's gonna come out
versus this one but there's this project
that i've been following for a long time
like over a year now um that i think is
just starting to get popularity uh and
it should it deserves it it's called the
mystery flesh pit and if you guys don't
know about the mystery flush bit is just
like this
crazy world building exercise
uh like legitimately i i've been
following it for
i think i found it like a year ago now
and i've been just clamoring every time
there's a new update from the person
that made it uh just like oh can't wait
but if you want to get something that's
like
surreal world building horror
you gotta check out the mystery flush
bit i was talking about before but it
reminds me a lot of like discover my
bodies and that kind of attitude about
just biology like
body horror is not really something that
i've i've always been very interested in
but
in a weird way this combines elements of
body horror
in with cosmic horror
in a weird way and that's so cool
that's it's so cool and i know like
that's not a new concept but just the
way it does it and it talks about this
thing this thing that you want to know
what the thing is like but but the thing
the thing about the thing is like you
can't know too much about the thing
because that ruins the mystique of what
the thing actually is it's just oh you
gotta look it up there's a tumbler that
they have but mystery flush bit it's
just such a cool thing there's a couple
videos that are explaining it but it's
kind of got the same
same kind of like grandiose feeling to
it that you get about like the scp
foundation you know
the scp foundation as a whole not
specifically to a specific scp but the
entire thing as a whole that's the kind
of vibe that you know the the the epic
grand scale of it all is kind of vibe
that you get out of mystery flush bit
and that's
super
super neat
super neat wicked neat man i'm almost
done actually which is weird
i didn't think that i was almost done
that engine needs a lot of work let's
see if i can get up here uh yeah yeah
actually let me get in here first
yeah this hydraulic piping also is going
to be a to find all the little
nooks
i see you
snorkel
[Music]
that's a little better now let's get
this engine
which is just gonna be an orange glowing
nightmare i knew it it's an orange
glowing nightmare yeah let's go from the
front
oh
i bet there's someone of you out there
that knows exactly what this thing is
and how it works specifically right down
to the detail because you're you you
were a helicopter kid and i'm not saying
that like that's weird you should be
embarrassed about it you should be proud
of it but my god how do you know so much
about helicopters that's okay
that's all right
i'm not gonna judge you too hard wait
did i get everything up here
no way no way did i
hang on a second
[Music]
oh my god i'm almost done oh the snorkel
i'll end on the dick
i'll end this adventure on the dick as i
always do okay tail rotor drive shaft
all right i'll finish it off on the
shaft and the dick
hill rotor drive shaft didn't i get oh
up here okay
there's still some more here
and now the dick
ah the undercarriage of the dong
of the schlong this is definitely a
schlong
you can't exactly call this a dick it's
a schlong dirt finder i need your
assistance at the mansion is a matter of
greatest urgency mayor jeff jefferson
the 13th
that sounds like a goddamn curse
look at that look at that
oh good they took the glows out of it
okay that was something that bothered me
about the time lapse before is that the
glows were involved in it and now that
the glows are out of there that's much
better so i feel better about doing the
glows oh my god someone with too much
time and egg on their hands has seen fit
to bombard my magnificent abode with
ballistics most foul don't ask me why
i'm as fair noble amer as this town has
ever seen as i'm sure you appreciate
security is at a premium right now so
i'm afraid i won't be allowing you onto
my property instead i have provided you
with a voucher for an extra long washer
extension it's for the cheapest one i'm
not made of money one last thing there
might be a small element of graffiti on
the gates please remove that as well
for an extra long
wait
how long we talk in here
also fascinating that i'm not allowed on
your property but
extra long extension available in the
shop how
how long
oh wow
oh my that that's long that is long but
excuse me you cheap
cheap son of a
i will uh
i only go for the most primo of primos
so
you can just shut your
dirty mouth
what
in the hell happened to this place
how long is long hang on how how long is
long
it's not that long
okay it's kind of long
good look at the thing do i have any
ladders or anything like that can i run
away
mountains what's with the vista over
here can i get launched into space again
that'd be nice this van doesn't seem as
big as a wait a minute this van is way
smaller
i've cleaned this van many times i know
that this is not to scale
that something's not right about this
van what the sign doesn't need to be
cleaned
all right fine
[Music]
i'm not going to do this in this episode
i'll save this for the next one thank
you everybody so much for watching i
appreciate you being here i appreciate
you enjoying this video
these are fun these are just so much fun
i love
i love power washing simulator it's just
a goddamn good time you know that's all
it is nothing like washing helicopter
dicks to make your day a little brighter
so thank you everybody so much for
watching hope you enjoyed this let me
know what you thought down in the
comments below and remember to give me
that list of games that i have not
finished i would love to know no
promises on finishing them but i'd love
to know what they are so i can rub them
in your face again or maybe finish them
we'll see thank you and as always i will
see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you